the revolution hasn't died in Syria's
Northwest these people were forced from
their homes in the recent russian-backed
Syrian government offensive that took
control of the northern countryside of
Hama province and many towns in Eid libs
house including khan shaykhun at least
half a million Syrians have been
displaced since the end of April we the
people of hon shake hoon we are not
asking Assad to allow us to return to
our town we will never accept his rule
our revolution will continue until the
downfall of this criminal regime it's
been relatively calm since the August 31
ceasefire but many people living in Eid
Lib fear it's only a matter of time
before President Bashar al Assad's
forces resume their military operation
that has already killed more than 1,000
civilians the Syrian opposition believes
there is a deal to prevent the
humanitarian crisis from worsening there
was an agreement between Turkey and
Russia to create a demilitarized zone
free of weapons and fighters on the
international terrorism list the zone
will be patrolled by Russia and Turkey
the Syrian interim government will take
over governance from high Italian
al-sham which will have to be disbanded
the situation in Idlib was discussed
this week between Syria's power brokers
who support opposing sides but work
together under the so-called Astana
process turkey made clear its priorities
to prevent a humanitarian crisis and a
large influx of refugees into the
country Russia and Iran focused on the
fight against those they call terrorists
but it seems they found middle ground
operations in Italy in terms of time and
location and by that way and at the
other side of this agreement there's
also an ongoing process in it've as you
know it's about the dissolution of HTS
because there is a great pressure from
the bottom from the people that many
Syrians have taken to the streets
demanding hi Italia Shem leaves adlib
they accused the armed group of abusing
power and failing to defend territory
ts is considered a terrorist
organization by the international
community because of its links with
al-qaeda
hi octahedra Shem was the reason why
last year's deal between Turkey and
Russia on the creation of a
demilitarized zone in Italy was never
implemented it refused to cooperate
forcing it to withdraw would have
required mainstream opposition factions
engaging in a internal war that would
have weakened their position these avi
pro-government forces it's not clear if
HTS will cooperate this time or whether
there is a timetable to this apparent
deal between Turkey and Russia but it
seems a large-scale offensive has been
put on hold for now and Russian
President Vladimir Putin is openly
discussing limiting anti-terror
operations in it Lib senator al jazeera
Beirut